back in the early nineties Nintendo
actually thought it was a great idea to
let a bunch of talentless jackasses it's
like me make game starring their
valuable franchise characters like Mario
and Zelda so you're talking about you're
not talking hahahaha yes I am the
philips cd-i hell no hell yes people
like that show area talk about the bad
wii game so much so now we're going to
play some terrible CDI games Infinity's
lesson we're going to be talking about
nintendo and phillips and sony and all
the various business arrangements that
they got into back in the early 1990s
with the dawn of CD based video gaming
now originally Nintendo and Sony were
going to team up to produce a machine
they were going to call the Nintendo
PlayStation but when that partnership
got dissolved Nintendo decided to
partner with American electronics
company Phillips and Nintendo but
Philips use some of its properties like
Mario and Zelda when they made their
video game system the CBI Thank You
professor Kohler for that informative
history lesson now let's actually play
some CDI games I've got here hotel Mario
which should be interesting a baker what
have you got over there yeah I'm not
talking to you right now okay it looks
like Baker is holding on to some zelda
games link to the faces of evil and
zelda the wand of gamilon against their
thought process and this was why make
just one bad zelda game why not make too
so to illustrate the raw power of the
cd-rom medium every one of these games
begins with a high-tech animated opening
it's like link zelda in a crazy homeless
person right there in your living room
and his minions have seized the island
of Korra died she
it sure is boring around here yeah sure
is boring here in mspaint lamb man screw
winwaker this cell shading is the real
deal it is written it is written here
that fish trees scribble ampersands
quite a lot we are off wow what are all
those heads these are the faces of evil
you must conquer each I guess I'd better
get going here is the map where do you
and I want to go to a different game
where's that on this map is it over here
he jumps he can jump Lincoln jump he
also sucks he jumps and sucks if people
can't see this but the controls are
really among the worst either and I'm
dead it's clear that the designers were
fans of the platforming in zelda 2 it's
also clear that the designers were
incompetent morons interesting fact II
oh I can't make jokes I'm too depressed
ah go talk to that octopus I bow down to
the site of this guy's three frame
animation loop help diamond froze the
fountain I'm stuck I know just how you
feel and here's the animated opening
again remember that show dr. Katz on
Comedy Central this makes dr. Katz look
like Miyazaki father you can't go who
will put drops in my freakishly unleaded
eyes and Link empa don't worry Zelda the
Triforce of wisdom promises the king
will safely return you know I ship sails
in the morning I wonder what's for
dinner oh boy I can't wait to bomb some
dodongos I can't wait to bomb some
dodongos that was actually my yearbook
quote I can't wait to bomb some dodongos
note how it actually somehow looks worse
than the last game now how many frames
do you account in that walking animation
they're uh three no no too honestly what
makes you think killing this thing is
even possible the last game link had
snow balls she doesn't even have snow
balls I love how progressive they
thought they were being oh yeah I know
we're gonna make a delta game where you
play as zelda girl power yeah take that
patriarchy it's very egalitarian the
boys can have an awful time with the
link game the girls can have an awful
time with the zelda game so how much did
people pay for this thing ah like around
four hundred dollars or so and that
that's in 1993 money so I think like
three thousand dollars today those poor
fools are like the only people in the
world who are jealous and their friends
who drop seven hundred bucks on a 3d oh
and another animated opening color I
think you're Mario drawing was actually
better than night snow yeah see you get
it I wasn't exaggerating at all no no
this is a this is hotel Mario oh my god
and it's a shame they couldn't get the
the top notch voice talent from the
Saturday morning cartoon show I guess
captain Lou albano was doing a TV ad for
buick dealership in Poughkeepsie that is
now a permanent guest at one of my seven
Koopa hotels I dare you to find her if
you can we gotta find the princess and
you gotta help us if you need
instructions on how to get through the
hotels check out the enclosed
instruction book if you have any
questions as to how to return this game
read your store receipt so what does
this have to do with that intro we just
watched uh you're rescuing Princess
Toadstool from a hotel from a hote so
it's like she didn't pay her bill she
got in hock at the mini bar I think she
might opened up one of those hundred
dollar bottles of all swatter they leave
on the counter so the objective here is
to clothes all of the doors on each
level it's a puzzle game with no puzzles
what's hilarious to me is people
actually debate over whether super mario
sunshine was a bad game well this exists
I love how hotel Mario is considered to
be quote the
good game of all those Nintendo CDI
titles this is known as Stockholm
Syndrome so I'm looking at this game and
I'm wondering why does this require a
cd-rom you've you hit the nail on the
head Baker that is the very question
that Nintendo ask themselves and finding
no answer they cancelled the cd-rom hat
on having not screwed up Zelda enough
with the first two games philips took
another crack at it with zelda's
adventure now this time I'm sure they're
gonna get it right apparently in the
intervening years they've learned to
write English in Hyrule no more
gobbledygook hey my grandma had that
necklace that's from TJ Maxx it is you
princess zelda with this magic pendant
go forth and with each side you gather
so too will you gain doubt it find your
magic wand use it wisely and listen to
your allies along the way
what the hell come on maker it's photo
realism in the future this is what all
games will look like it's real it's like
Mortal Kombat and Zelda had a baby but
she got punched in the stomach while she
was pregnant is this considered part of
the timeline or these zelda games
canonical are you kidding me they're
totally economical this must have cost
him like ten bucks no canonical uh oh I
doubt it Nintendo Zelda games don't even
have any continuity to begin with I mean
how many times does link save Zelda for
the first time ever hey I got a
boomerang now the fun begins hey it's a
boomerang that doesn't come back when
you throw it oh they tried so hard and
now for the bonus round now you know
Baker the saga of the CD I wasn't quite
as terrible as it could have been thanks
again for inviting me to be part of this
I really appreciate it man how could it
possibly be worse no don't tell me no
because Nintendo pulled the plug before
Phillips could screw up its flagship
franchises even more this is an
unreleased prototype called super
Mario's wacky world's so super mario
world is like my favorite game ever they
actually tried to do a sequel to it yes
and by they we mean some random european
developer or whatever they didn't get
very far there's no gameplay yet just to
really hack together engine and some art
here give it a try why are the turtles
wearing Centurion helmets oh cuz it's
Egypt oh wait that still doesn't make
sense hilariously enough they were still
kind of figuring it out with this game I
mean they were they were sort of
actually getting it yeah this is not
even one percent finish and it's
actually better than the other games
even though there's nothing to do it's
like it doesn't hurt to play it but even
still these guys seriously actually
thought they were going to march into a
meeting with Miyamoto and be like huh
huh you don't want to make mario world 2
anymore right right want to give it to
us look look at the coop ahead and
vomits water huh it's non-interactive
I hate your color can I go now you just
don't appreciate genius I'm being very
serious when I say that Nintendo got
really close to releasing a cd-rom
add-on for the Super Nintendo in fact a
game you might have played secret of
mana was originally designed as a game
for the cd-rom add-on secret of mana
it's what you would get if you combined
the sword-swinging action of the old
legend of zelda games and dropped in the
leveling up character building stat
boosting mechanics of Final Fantasy the
multiplayer mode really kicked it into
high gear and made it one of the true
classics of the 16-bit era sadly Square
Enix is yet to come close to replicating
the perfect peanut butter and chocolate
design genius of mana the world of mana
series didn't even feature an action RPG
entry just lame dungeon hacks and a
middling realtime strategy game but fans
of the genre should definitely take a
look at the recently released Final
Fantasy crystal chronicles ring of fates
for a Nintendo DS while it's not a mana
game by name it feels a lot like 1
unlike the multiplayer-focused game cube
original ring of fates is primarily a
single player game there's a well-told
story with some wonderfully written
dialogue I was surprised at how much I
cared about these goofy little deformed
guys gameplay is fast and furious you
won't have time to work out much in the
way of strategy you'll just have to hack
and slash your way through dungeons full
of monsters it's not nearly as complex
as a main line Final Fantasy game but
the combination of the two disparate
mechanics is what's so appealing here
ring of fates does have a lot of issues
your computer controlled partner
characters or idiots who never do
anything useful using magic is
cumbersome to the point that I never
bothered except to heal myself and
although there's an extensive
multiplayer mode there's no online play
so you're going to have to track down
somebody else with a copy of the game
Final Fantasy crystal chronicles ring of
fates gameplay issues are substantial
enough that if you are not dying for a
secret of mana revival you can skip this
game but if you're like me
you need it i give it a seven out of 10